the back is broken beyond repair
that's good
I wanted to go back
stuck yours no yarn us
I can jam you all day that's what she
said
I can't go back and get oil
weird
I thought it was done
so what else
a queue
build a [ __ ] ladder up there
I never gonna try these stupid ideas
mates
and I come
then what
I seriously just want to try it for once
all right
ah
that's
Oh
a dance
impossible to
Heather
I'm Isleta
surprise I've used it I work
it's not were never peed a it was a bad
idea but it would have been cool
don't look like one of those that you
plow
at least I think it is
but I mean where should I go then I mean
a few days
stuff
is this side working spell
also stop
I'm also stuck course you are
just trial and error seriously
because I gotta find a new car wheel
maybe
I haven't seen one
sorry that was my stick
it's gonna be some way to lift that
Oh
it was that simple
goddamnit
so typical meet like Oh
where am I just gonna run all the way
through
through that for the action oh it was
only one door
so now we can head back to the sewers
it's why the [ __ ] not
the Red detained burst from the walls as
if they had begun to bleed he cried out
in fear as a spectacle began to consume
diversion
pleasant one of very few pleasantries
three-sixty jump shot I was stupid
all right
think I need any more oil there is no
need to fill it again got answered
pretty millage right
what the hell that I drained you you're
telling me I'm not done there
well there aren't I an idiot I had to
miss something maybe there's like an on
and off switch I tend to miss those
sent back
I wanna see so tall when I walk in
back to the control room the blue light
blinded him as he had done inside the
murky tambien ouch area it was just
undauntingly tried to approach it but
the barest firm hand held it back
oh there is
not completely busted closest to the
door system oh I forgot about this still
stuck
not done
but but I thought thanks
if two or one
other other stuff why are they stuck why
I won't be honest
that'd be great
maybe I'm not supposed to stuff
there's definitely nothing more I could
definitely done
these are down again who I should be
cipolla mine
are you guys down how about bring you up
I'll bring you guys up
all right
did
um
[ __ ]
why are you stuck
ah annoying annoying
all right
that I solve it
I don't know
I mean if I had really had solve it
these two were identical then these
steering wheels should look exactly the
same as these things but they aren't
I'm pretty sure I solved it anyways so
let's just head back
did sound like something great
beautiful while orchids seemed a
testament to Nate to nature strength
being able to grow inside Brendan Byrne
Alice it was Alexander studies and care
which enabled the flower to blossom yay
hope it's drain now otherwise I'll look
really stupid
come to do a 360 jump shot this
Gladys shot 360 yeah
it's so awesome if there
brutha monster was there could be like
um and it's not drink mother of [ __ ]
all right